elle s'est rabattue formant alors voilà
à nice enel et surya
ça te revoir de choisir celles
débarquées mouse soda ou sur des
bâtiments
oh
alain en belgique il y en a qui m'a été
le nombre jadoul finir toi ça m'amuse
clients et nos bourses à la en blé vial
de l'internet
il y à cette situation parce qu' il dise
ah je voudrais loyers sur le champ c'est
très vital est très important très
important pour qui elle est toujours en
contact avec eux et il y en a des gens
qui laissent les parents la famille pour
les rassurer il le pose des questions
comment vous trouvez la bonne attaque un
art qui est un client mardi dernier
téléphone
elle en année nous
le dites nous tout
avant sa venue dans l'aura qui m'a
raconté
yannick entre sa date les mises au vert
qui téléphonent de tarascon souffle
house abbas à kizza
c'est long de la madame que ça fait 37
ans qui ont sont à vue j'imaginais après
3 septembre selon quatre au canada
c'est émouvant et bénévoles avoir
beaucoup perdu
bref on est très très jeune femme et
enfant de sa famille qui l'a jamais
connue donc c'est quelque chose de
quelque chose c'est une étape de la vie
qu'on a on a souvent pensé et rêvé à ça
et aujourd'hui ça se concrétise
moi je veux donner des verts je veux
donner des petites sql départ est donné
devant des amis de la famille
desjonquères elle ne connaît pas d'être
mort mais quelqu'un a faim connaître
mais juste le fait que c'est des gens
qui qui prennent soin d'eux qui est qui
qui les aime qui sont là pour les
supporter c'est ce qui s'appelle
la bataille
et
avec ces jeunes filles ont quitté nous
laisser tous leurs biens d'abord dans
nos poches
peut-être quelques sous qui ont sauvé
mais l'on sait le réseau qui est c'est
son nom comme nous à l'heure l'oncle de
maroussi cette instance ne supporte plus
mais quand son tout seul c'est vraiment
difficile
si vous étiez parole parce qu'ils
seraient prêts à y peut rien faire allô
allô allô et on ferme un téléphone on
peut effectivement généralement acquis
12 euros régis bailleul à la scène
le haut
famille
nous avons prévu aujourd'hui l'accueil
de différentes familles et l'ouzo alors
je vous êtes vous un produit lorsque
nous avons cuisiné aujourd'hui c'est
comme tout ce que nous avons vu et pour
nous c'est très très important de
réseaux c'est difficile c'est difficile
en tenant compte du contexte vécu de la
politique d'aidé d'un tas de choses et
on veut pas aussi on leur demande
on n'impose rien du tout mais on fait en
sorte que les gens sortent c'est très
important
j'ai tapé la nature du mal à se dire aux
canadiens qui adoptera ce dimanche je
suis en train de dire à la même question
est-ce que vous avez expérience canadien
c'est la première fois que j'avais
quitté sa maison diplomation quand ils
sortent
ce